How can a disorder as common
as autism go so undiagnosed
and so unnoticed within women?
Well, a part of the answer is
that many girls who have autism
observe the way others
around them behave,
realize that they are different,
then change the way they
act in order to fit in.
After I was diagnosed,
I felt as though I truly
understood myself.
It gave me relief, clarity,
and the ability to learn more
about myself and my brain.
There is beauty in the spectrum.
I encourage those of you with autism
to unmask and be your genuine self.
Whether you are neurotypical
or neurodivergent,
I urge all of you to remember that
there is value in our differences,
and acknowledging them allows
for more authentic relationships.